listening to you two you sound like
a couple that's been divorced that are
just good friends now and reminiscing
hello everyone hola mis amigos
you're listening to oh my god hi
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
omg hi oh my god
ever pull into the driveway after a trip
to the grocery store only to realize you
forgot that one key ingredient for
dinner
now you have options get the groceries
you need or a backup meal from your
favorite local restaurant delivered with
doordads what about you if you forgot
condoms and that night you were gonna
for a limited time our listeners get 25
off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter the code omghi
download the doordash app and enter code
omghi
for this when cbd isn't enough and
traditional thc is too much enjoy the
smooth buzz of diet smoke
you know diet smoke delivers a balanced
medium high and you know i'm going to
tell you why i know it works because
when i said balanced medium-high
i felt really good saying it like you
know i had one before but
just
their product is highly functional thc
that comes in the form of a delicious
gummy
but hide them from the kids
or not i don't even [ __ ] who your kids
are go to dietsmoke.com and use the
promo code omg hi improves your eyesight
as well go to dietsmoke.com and use the
promo code
omghi for 20
off your order that's omghi
and that's
dietsmoke.com promo code omg hi for 20
off
so so um tell me about let's talk about
the new show yes the new show is called
with love
with love and it is when it airs
december 17th on amazon prime
that's good yeah it's we latinx people
we made it to rom-com like a whole
family and we've never like thirty how
often do we love rom-coms i know you
were you guys new year's day or you were
in that one right but there was only one
of you
that's right okay so we got the whole
family and it's rom-com there's a little
bit of sexiness oh you saw em rodriguez
no rom-com what no
romantic comedy oh dale i'm very sorry
romantic comedy um but you know
gloria calderon kellett who wrote this
series is brilliant she's just she
reminds me of anne just like she's like
a mama bear she's gonna make everything
happen she is our 900 pound gorilla
she's so um
so smart and so you know she worked with
norman lear on one day at a time wow
yeah she she is a heavy hitter so she
wrote these scenes
then casted these people where literally
they could handle drama and comedy and
her scenes go from
something super funny to something
really heartfelt and dealing with a an
intense subject and then it's funny
again and all the actors
it's just beautiful and every episode is
a different holiday
oh that's cool so we start with
christmas then we go to new year's then
we go to valentine's day then we go to
fourth of july and then dia de los
muertos
so it's only a seven episode it's only
five it's only five it's only five well
so this is the fastest show i think for
amazon as far as production it was
pitched in january we shot it in summer
and now it's coming in december on the
head of amazon
okay how's that show coming along
what's it called with love
oh that's what the latinos are hey get
them in and out as fast as you can let's
just do every holiday
no stop at thanksgiving
they actually had to make a montage
in
who's the person of amazon um they had
to make a montage for some they had to
because it was original so you guys
shooting
seven different seasons and when it as
you go do you do you do
christmas and new year's and
in the same week and then they put them
together or no no one so you follow the
the diaz family um you see us at noche
buena um christmas eve and all the
traditions and fun things that we do and
then the next time you see us it's new
year's and the next time you see us it's
valentine's day so you see all the
relationships progress
over the months over the holidays do you
like your husband yes benito martinez
from the shield is he as good a husband
plug your ears jordan your husband is
george i
take the fifth what am i going to do i'm
not worried
better husband than me well i haven't
been around in 120 episodes we've only
done five
give him a chance to grow
hey man where's the reboot until we
reboot i'm going to be with any other
husband that they'll pay me to be with
am i in the palm of our hands
you do we had it i know what happened
can we talk about that
yeah what time after we talk about with
gloves okay okay so have you done them
all already no we shot them all summer
all through covid okay it's brutal
so
do you watch amazon uh what's it called
prime amazon prime video yep so
everybody that has an amazon account do
they we're there
if you have amazon prime account yeah if
you have amazon prime you get part of
the entertainment free yeah yeah yeah
it's part of it okay
and there's a there's a a billion things
on amazon right right like you put you
could put in anything but you know what
you can do is what um what's the easiest
way to find shows you like
um you know i don't know yet with love
and it comes up and people are adding
we're asking people to add it to their
watch list because that almost counts as
like ratings ahead of
us premiering and all five episodes are
gonna stream they're all gonna drop at
the same time so it's not coming back
you're not coming back next year
the show's not coming back hopefully we
do oh so they'll go again and oh yeah
well if everybody watches and it does
really work
they'll pick it up new holidays yeah why
not martin luther king day you know some
bad [ __ ] happens every holiday
president's holidays
no maybe we'll get more holidays we'll
get groundhog day
during groundhog day
does he wear sombrero
that'd be pretty cool
all right so so it's a continuous if it
went five years it would go with the
same cast and the best part is that it
deals with love in your thirties
single who's that couple in the thirties
playing my daughter she's kind of trying
to figure out love my uh she's a
i didn't know i asked my wife and says
well i don't know if it was her real
daughter or the daughter on the show hey
i'm not that old yes i am yes i am
next time she comes out that's a respect
no no so emra but mark in delicato that
you might remember from ugly betty he
was a young kid in ugly betty the one
that was
yeah yeah he's gay and the best part is
you know i pray that grunts a lot of
times that's what it meant
i speak all of his little sounds that he
makes
see i don't know what benito's little
under his breath
sayings are yet i know yours so yeah um
we have a lot of aapi did you put your
five episodes with him up against my car
five [ __ ] it's like when people used to
say who's funnier edward james almost or
george lopez and i'd be like what the
what are you doing
not standing next to me
i hope i didn't lose many of those
that is pretty funny though he can be
funny all right so
moving right along all right so they so
they is the family they're all related
right they're not friends and family
they're all well we have each of their
relationships okay with their own
individual families
no no it's all my family and all my kids
boyfriends and uh yeah i guess
boyfriends and the journey of their love
and then in the 50s you know all of us
who've been in long-term relationships i
think a lot of women in america are
going to be able to relate to this
because so you get the man in your
dreams you have your kids you have your
good business and you've been married
like 30 years and then like it's on
automatic pilot like he don't care about
you you don't care about him you're
friends but you know the magic is gone
but it happens not a new guilt that are
you true brother
but in this relationship it does happen
so my character kind of does things to
rattle the cage a little bit um that i
can't say and then we have renee victor
and pepe serna do you know pepe serena
yeah oh yeah what are they playing
they're they're they're they're my 50s
they're my parents no i'm the 50s and
they're my pa love in the 70s
so it's pretty cool
pepe serena was auditioning uh he he
wanted to be
uh gil carrillo in in
a in a movie of your life yeah who did
they get gabriel
danny devito
oh my god this is a tough room
it's not tougher than any room that you
and i've been in i know i'm used to it i
have like scar tissue all over my body
what are you drinking water or drinking
beer to drink water no no all right you
know why i look like this because i
don't drink beers at like two o'clock in
the afternoon man
only once it's like vegas there's no
clock in here
and who played you who ended up playing
you ah
a martinez oh i love a nice man he's not
i don't love him as much as you but he's
been around a long time he's a nice nice
man and he had a brother who was a
deputy i think we can say that a
martinez i would say is one of the
latino actors who is the most underrated
yeah because what that guy did
is he worked
i think from the seventies were soap
operas back then eighties he had he was
uh with him is that right i was i was
his the other woman in the a storyline
on santa barbara i was there for two
years with a martinez he was in it he
had some cracks at tv like main tv
didn't go very long but he kept working
yeah and you know but they weren't
giving us shots back then but he stayed
in he stayed in the middle
yeah you know like uh uh who's the other
one um
sal lopez i just saw yeah
like they stayed in there he did
something when i met with him because he
was gonna
be me in a made for television movie
and he said you know they had me they
had
my partner frank salerno being you know
nice dresser he says and they had
a martinez getting soap suits off the
rack
and he says i'm looking at you and you
you're not a you're a nice dresser
and the only thing i had them change was
and it really came out good they had
cops sitting in the car they had me
sitting in the car with frank and we're
eating donuts and i said i'll be honest
with you i said i i don't eat donuts you
know did you guys ever did you guys ever
eat those i never ate donuts i still
don't eat donuts today i you know i'm
not a sweet eater
and i said you want to have me eat i
don't mind you
eating but hey give me a taco give me a
burrito get something so the scene is
they're in the car we have to watch that
and he's eating the burrito
oh
and you know a's going to want to make
sure that it is true and it's
partner
uh
who's portraying frank says oh really
and it was hey
this is what aztec warriors used to eat
it's the most beautiful thing
of all do you know it's self-contained
yeah there it is you can put whatever
you want in it to go you can eat and
drive right with it and who played uh
did he get he got the part he got and
who played frank
jordan there is he's not dead i want to
say
the camera oh i can't remember his name
that's the way we talk
to my friend james i don't think he's
dead yet
no he passed away he
oh i don't remember we're going to pour
a little beer out for him yeah
for the brothers who aren't here
so okay so
with love with love and who who are what
are the other ones go down 30s and 40s
50 60. so we've got 30 we got 30s 50s
and 70s so renee victor i met her she
plays my mom and she also plays my mom
on my other amazon show undone
um that's we shot season one and then
we're waiting for season two to come out
are you guys going to get picked up
it's rotoscope yeah thank you we wrote a
scope we remember scanner darkly with um
keanu reeves and winona ryder do you
remember that
it's uh yeah it's it's hard to describe
i'll pull up an image i only watch it
basically they shoot stories on youtube
live action people fool's gone wild
that's what you do
people falling down no no they turn us
they shoot live-action scenes and then
they turn us into graphic novels oh
right that's right yeah like that that's
from is that from scanner darkly maybe
yeah
over here with camera reeves okay well
look up undone it's beautiful so
basically it takes in it no the only
thing i show them the art the only thing
i watch on amazon prime right now is
bosh i'm hooked on it oh i remember i
didn't use it
you see a la sheriff yeah lapd yeah is
it good
i like it is it good yeah all of it i
auditioned for it they didn't give it to
me so i don't watch it your sister
oh jackie i don't know is she she did it
yeah oh really oh yeah
yeah
is it good yeah it's good really good or
just good it's good
oh i really like it i want good people
to work nice people should always get
jobs that's that's my motto yes you know
i think i think i hate when the
funky you know you know how
real i kept i tried to keep our show
early on
there was an issue i would say allegedly
with anne's sister
in in fort lauderdale hey hey lingerie
and then we came back
and
we made the show
her sister played by jack lee open door
you remember what her name was jackie
oberdore what was her name on the show
veronica no that was our knees okay
anyways i can't remember but this was
taken out of a
real situation
where i opened the door and sister was
there and she was in like a middle of
the day and i was like hey hey lingerie
because she was wearing lingerie very
revealing
and she opened the door like that
allegedly
so when we went back to do the show i
told anne of course and there was that
was a rough time of course
but also i used the
the term when in the show when she
turned around george and she's in her
laundry i went
hey
that was one of my favorite lines when i
come in you go hey did you talk to your
sister and i go yes she apologized and
then i gave her her hair back
that was one of my favorites they were
always great man you know what this show
makes me laugh to this day like whenever
people you know they they'll be wherever
in some hotel and they'll be like look
we can't get away from you you're right
you're always there
i'm telling you i was
six seven episodes all night like
couldn't sleep yeah on a hotel uh
hotel the hotel a lot of people say your
show got me through really hard times my
daughter was going through a divorce we
were really upset and we watched it and
i i just think and it makes me laugh
still
and luna marie my daughter na it was not
appropriate she would she did not have a
daughter right while the show was on
right and we might have played you know
if she had i tried it my uterus would
not cooperate and if you had i mean
we would have wrote it into the show
which would have been interesting you
know we talked we did a little thing
with a
pregnancy type false positive yeah but
um
so at what point did she start to
understand that you
were like in in the business of
well she had been on set since uh she
was two and a half right since i did
switched at birth you know because it
was 14 hours i thought i was literally
going to be put out to pasture on an abc
family show as the mom it was going to
be all about the kids and unfortunately
it was not it was one of the hardest
jobs i ever did i had to learn sign
language i worked 14 hour days and i had
a two and a half year old baby and i
would literally be at work at five in
the morning and they would make these
big long days for me and then i had like
four hours down time so i'd drive back
home to see my daughter and then come
back and shoot into the night it was i
had two nannies
it was just it was it was really really
hard so that was up there in santa cruz
and you know i did st george up there
and i saw her up there uh we hadn't seen
each other no
i came to say hi
it's pretty cool man and bam
i was directing yeah
so whenever whenever um
it's like what if you had been in a
championship team and you see your guys
from the other team and you guys were
champions that was you know you're in
frank's special relationship like i see
constance it's like you know i can see
being part of that
are we short on time or one oh no i
haven't even
[Laughter]
so what
so you've seen have you seen all the
episodes yes
let's go through the let's go through
the issues of each couple in the first
one is what they're in the 30s yes when
we have a guy who's been married here
gil gil has been married
for over 50 years
let's see how the 26th of december will
be 51.
let's see how close love is to with love
okay oh real love started now okay so in
the 30s right the arc who are the
characters uh martin delicato plays my
son jorge jr and then emerald tobaya
plays my daughter uh lily and she has
the guy who's perfect on paper but
there's it's just not right for her and
she's trying to go through the motions
she's trying to figure it out what does
she want she's your daughter-in-law not
your daughter no she's my daughter okay
and so she's struggling with that and
she break well i can't i don't want to
give any anything you can okay and so
then um mark uh finds like
an amazing amazing guy for himself but
deals with all the self-esteem things of
like you know everybody's always looking
for the perfect person and then when you
find the perfect person you have to
think you deserve the perfect person and
there's all kinds of weird things get
triggered
mr 51 is there
a perfect love a perfect person or do
you take
somebody that you connect to and you
kind of find each other like a like a
combination
i gotta believe that you you start and
then you find and work out and
it just it's not perfect in the
beginning right no no but if you hang in
there
right people tend to give up soon on
relationships now where they think oh
you know this isn't going to today
everybody gives up but if you find
somebody who's willing to work with you
and do the work i think that's huge
anybody that says marriage is easy has
never been married
you know that that's it life is not easy
no and and now
i owe everything really to my spouse i
mean she's she's the the glue
that has kept us together it was hard on
her
no financial reward
after the documentary dropped i had to
apologize for her because i didn't
realize how much fear she was really
entering oh my god yeah because i would
imagine i was totally focused on
you know the case
and her job was the house and the kids
and that's why i saw the
documentary i don't know what they had
planned to do with it but watching a
documentary which is really about one of
the most notorious circles of all time
but
the stories of him and his family and
him knowing
the girl and knowing the mom and going
like and i mean
that [ __ ] happens like in
andy griffith like you somebody takes
their truck and he knows who it is oh
yeah yeah i mean this guy all that [ __ ]
even a nice talker [ __ ] happened like
almost right where you lived yeah right
there when you live we found some
footprints around my house he had
changed shoes
and uh he hit in diamond bar which is a
city which is way up there man it's way
up there five minutes away from my house
you know so he
hit all around he went to your house
well we found some [ __ ] when we came
back from uh
oh we were out in orange county uh the
last one he did
and we came back a week for his arrest
and when i came back i found footprints
but it wasn't the avia he had changed
shoes because they yeah and so from that
time we got surveillance around my house
you know taking care of me but there
were shoe prints there that shouldn't
have been where they were and where they
went
from yeah
so dianne feinstein if you guys haven't
heard nightstalker
they had done all this work in l.a
but then they had heard that there was
some conversation in san francisco
we went up to san francisco we briefed
them we told them what we were looking
for and it was so important
january 9th 1985 1356 pair model 440 if
he has landed in new york from taiwan
for distribution throughout the u.s
sixth pair ended up in the state of
california one pair in l.a and she put
it out
what they tracked all that down because
it was a certain shoe right and they had
only made a hundred they they
only delivered six to california and
they tracked it down to the one pair
that they sold in l.a and then dianne
feinstein has a press conference and
releases that they're looking for this
shoe richard richard will tell us later
the shoes went over the golden gate
bridge oh
he got rid of him and he changed shoes
he went to estadio which was a different
shoe and those are the kind of prints
that we had around my house we didn't
know the slot he was using
he went to his house nobody knows that
yeah and he said
that's an exclusive
it's on netflix
but you know night stalker you haven't
seen no not for a serial killer [ __ ]
half man
richard ramirez i don't want to know
anything about that dude if you look
yeah but now i know you yeah
but i'll watch the good part but it's is
that compound like his world and the
other frank was is still that way like
he's not a guy that gets a lot of
information out very close to chips but
he had his family so and especially in
that area so there's really kind of two
things
going on the chase for this guy
but then there's guys in this
detective's world like they're in their
world together right yeah
and a lot of people didn't believe that
what i was alleging one guy
was doing all of it they were doing it
they you know they had they they thought
it was yeah and they thought i was a
young young
young punk trying to make a name for me
but you were a young guy but you was a
young guy
at that time i was uh 34
yeah
that's an elderly well actually if you
get you know
the homicide bureau that's very good
[Laughter]
like a latino superstar cop you know
trying to
i swear to god we fight for everything
how about that
how about the guy that said this one
person gets shouted down by all the
other guys who have more experience in
him by saying it's two people and
they're all wrong yeah and and he said
they were like talking about he left the
room
yeah yeah yeah yeah dismissive of your
and you were right
so so she released that
over there because that guy was watering
the grass he goes what are you here for
the guy yeah yeah
so just in passing
some reporters show up from l.a that was
peter murder up there and then the guy's
watering the grass and he goes what are
you here for that guy that's drawing
pentagrams on the walls
and uh he was like what guy and they
went up and asked them i think they had
video of a mascot and they did not look
happy when they walked out of the house
that was a peter pan murderer if he
asked me it was still a mickey mouse
case peter oh [ __ ]
okay i didn't get that uh
peter pan mickey mouse
i'm sorry i can't track all the murders
peter pan uh tinkerbell yeah
peter pan tinkerbell you ever see those
uh videos on youtube when they do the
the explosions or fireworks at at disney
in the castle and ghosts fly out of the
castle like real ghosts no no
you guys anybody that's out there that
wants to check it out are they high are
they high when they see the game
this is after they put deeper this is
after they put us on on them
but no no it's really got them knobs
that you won't see
at [ __ ] knott's berry farm my
grandkids were watching
but ghosts at disneyland are way better
than not scary farmers from the room we
were in last night from the suite we
were in last night my grandkids six and
nine
were watching
disneyland the fireworks oh that's
awesome
were they did they see ghosts
no good do you do you agree with the 30s
relationship of with love that those are
the issues it's modern day
right because of the guy right okay now
what about what was so funny we come
back we got the night stalker we got the
peter pan and then we go oh let's talk
about whitlow and then
what's what's your relationship so my
relationship is you know that mid-life
thing where you've been with somebody
for 35 years and you love each other and
you're friends but there's not really
any passion and you you talk about your
kids together you maybe work together
you run the house together but it's
really you take each other for granted
gil does that happen is that true but
you were standing at at times it does 35
years in were you still working oh yeah
[ __ ] i i i retired 12 years ago oh [ __ ]
so what were the hours what are the
the hours were whatever the job demanded
homicide is not a job it's a lifestyle
so whatever the job takes my even my
wife knows
if
they call me up at three in the morning
because some somebody wants to talk in
the jail right now is the time to get up
and talk don't wait until nine in the
morning every morning that you got up
where did you go to first uh wherever
you needed to go or
i mean where did you go to second
after breakfast i used to meet my
partner at starbucks
you know
my partner is my best friend
and it's like you know you get up in the
morning is that frank at that time yeah
okay not not salerno frank gonzales okay
frankenstein and he was from the body
you know we had so much in common we
were brothers
and i drive down the pomona freeway and
bumper to bumper traffic and i tell
everybody it's like going to disneyland
you know your kids want to get up they
want to be the first ones in you get up
you hate it you start driving you're in
traffic
and then all of a sudden you see the d
for disneyland and parking you know and
g for goofy so all of a sudden you perk
up well i'd be in bumper to bumper
driveway i'd see the atlantic off-ramp
and i start to perk up let's get the
starbucks right up the street hit my
part man we're there wow we'd run all
day long we'd work whatever we had to do
hey it's getting a little hungry it's
time to grab something to eat
and we grab something we work some more
we keep going and pretty soon hey
you know we're done there ain't much to
do it's time to go home
so
time to go home you get back in that get
back on that freeway so it's different
every day every day every day
okay so your relationship you've been
with your wife for how many years 35
years and at any point does your wife
say you know frank we need more us time
frank we need to do this i'm i'm sorry
yeah
no willie franklin no can we talk about
this sorry
i'm sorry yeah
no but i'm saying as far as the
relationship like with love like the
only thing my wife asked me
during the relationship at the time i
was a
i was pretty i loved playing softball
just like i love coming here because you
come in here you forget about all the
problems that are outside this little
room right now i mean you play softball
somebody almost died in the audience on
saturday you didn't hear that really no
but it is like vegas there's no clock
we're cutting that out
san antonio we
we uh
you go play softball
and all the problems are gone you're
playing ball right well my wife was
complaining because i was playing three
days a week
and hey how about a little more you know
is that your free time us time you know
for the family so i did so i cut it down
to two see
i think that works yeah you listened and
some men
she's tough she's from the bottom yeah
yeah you're not gonna have to some men
don't listen look i can speak from
personal experience when the look the
first person who knows it's not working
is the woman
usually and and she will most definitely
that's a great one she will most
definitely tell you
what's not working and what needs to
happen now some men choose to be like
nah nah that's fine beat all distracted
or whatever those are the guys who are
always
completely shell-shocked when she leaves
right yeah she's been working on this
thing for two years and when she's done
it's done so almost like a detective was
smart he said okay i'll spend more time
okay
like walk in and go what are you going
to give me today
uh give me a name i can't give you a
name can you give me an area can you
give me a date can you only play no
i did
one day and i was frank was my partner
salerno
and no he knows my wife knew
that partners did everything together
so it was a sunday afternoon frank
called me up and he says hey listen i
got some stuff i got to do at my house
i know we're first up you get a murderer
give me a call i'll roll from home it's
not a problem
so a case came in and it wasn't a murder
it was an officer-involved shooting
so the lieutenant said hey we're going
to give it to these guys he says call
frank you know you guys will have the
assist
and he says where's frank i said well
he's at home he asked me to you know
i'll just call him he'll roll from home
he'll meet me there he said well let him
stay there dude he's got
roll out with dave he's here so i rolled
out with somebody else yeah okay so i'm
out there sunday afternoon
and
[Music]
my frank
calls my house later on that afternoon
he's a pro can i speak to gil and he
said well isn't he with you and then
frank starts to stutter because frank
doesn't know where i'm at
and he's already prepared to cover for
you right oh exactly yeah and
she just
he just thought well whenever yeah he
probably went out with somebody else but
whenever he gets here just have him give
me a call
so my wife because we had pagers in
bieber's right so i get a page and i
call the officers they call your wife at
home
so i called my wife at home and she says
where are you at
and i said i told you i rolled out on a
case i'm working
and she says oh
she says why is your partner calling you
at home oh [ __ ] unfortunate because we
didn't have cell phones i'm calling from
a phone booth right there
and i said uh hey listen there
i said are you by the television she
said yeah i said put on channel seven oh
there you go that's a good alibi i said
put on channel seven i said you see
henry alfaro talking out there doing a
live stand up she said yes i said look
across the street at the phone booth
who's in the phone booth yeah and she
goes
oh that's you i said i told you i'm
working
if i tell you i'm working i'm working
anyway coming out i gotta go
there you go and so she knew that i was
really working i was lying there it is
and my daughter the one's gonna be 50
tomorrow said you know what mom dad
could be out anyplace just tell you
please do it you have to take it
she was an understanding woman she's a
strong woman but you were smart enough
to listen to her when she needed
something i hope so and lucky enough to
have a camera
henry
you've got back-to-back meetings errands
to run and chores to take care of what's
the secret to clearing the to-do list a
little help from doordash you can get
dinner household essentials and
everything on your grocery list
delivered
what do you want to eat tonight
maybe you want a cooked favorite but
don't feel like going to the store
or you want something exciting and new
but it would be great to stay in tonight
doordash connects you with everything
you want whenever and however you want
it get what you want to eat right now
and right to your door with doordash
along with restaurants you love you can
now get groceries and other essentials
item delivered with your door dash
get drinks snacks and other household
items in under an hour
craving late night ice cream forget that
one key ingredient for dinner or maybe
you just need to stock up for the week
with doordash get everything in one app
for a limited time our listeners will
get 25 off and zero delivery fee on your
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app and enter the
code
hi that's omgh
off up to 10 value and zero delivery
fees on your first order when you
download the doordash app in the app
store and enter the code omg hi don't
forget that's code omg hi for 25 off
your first order with doordass subject
to change and terms apply you know my
problem with edibles sometimes you get
so
high
it can really be difficult to control
the dose there's nothing worse than
being baked out of your mind when you
didn't plan on it
and you know once you eat it there's no
going back
you just sit there suffering stoned out
of your mind that's why when i need the
perfect medium high
i hit up my friends at diet smoke for
their delicious delta h t8c gummies
delta 8 is simply a slightly less potent
thc the thc you're probably not familiar
with is delta 9 and while both are
natural to the cannabis plant
diet smoke product extracts their delta
8 from hemp
some may call this a loophole i call the
secret recipe to getting smooth stable
and most importantly
legally high
diet smoke is legal in most states and
non-prescription
just check diet smokes website to see if
they ship their delicious gummies to
your state so when cbd has enough and
traditional thc is too much enjoy the
smooth buzz of diet smoke go to
dietsmoke.com and use the promo code omg
hi for 20 off your order that is omghi
dietsmoke.com promo code
omghi for 20 off diet smoke delta 8 thc
gummies are not for use or sale to
people under the age of 21.
please use
responsibly don't be like me enjoying
your life
more with diet smoke
just for the buzz of it just for the
best smoke
that's the thing about love in the 50s
like and my character does my husband
doesn't listen to me
and um and i do things
but i cannot okay so
all right so it's a bit of a departure
for you
no it's not um
uh for for me as an actress yeah uh no
your character no as a character so you
go out on the town
right oh i can't give it away chandler
vogel
do you remember spencer vogel chandler i
watched too much friends uh spencer
vogel
yeah that was another good one yeah
there's there's so there's things
there's controversy but the best part
for me is
not only it just should couples watch
together or will the guy be there like
yeah can i watch this with my wife or am
i going to be a dog are they going to
look at you and go what the [ __ ]
i will tell you no no no it's not that
bad i mean it's still a rom-com romantic
comedy so um but there is some sexy time
in there and it's not me
it's the younger kids
um but not full nudity though no no no
you don't see it uh but it's it's funny
it's sexy
it's going to be lost on you guys but we
have some topless hunky men that are
going to be in the show
all married damn it i know i asked
no you you're not you don't want to get
married do you
um it because i made it this far without
getting married no but you said you know
earlier when you got here you said i'm a
child of the
70s yeah um
would you think you'd get married or do
you not i mean i mean you had
people with you but you never decided to
get married um i think because it seems
so antiquated you know i know and at
this point because the rules still apply
in marriage even though the times have
changed what rules you know honor what
the vows yeah because the vows were
love don't they say still say oh
sickness and in health and until death
but i'm not like a hardcore catholic or
anything
say that well that's why people change
the vows because the ones from the
church are pretty you're almost like hey
they're pretty strict
too much commitment for me um no
if somebody were to write their own
violence you could write what you wanted
from the other person but see i've been
single so long that you know but i've
been in long term my my where the father
of my daughter i was with him for 18
years so that's like a marriage um
i've been i'm on this side of it and
i've seen what 50 of them don't work
so um i don't have very many illusions
of how romantic it's going to be and i
don't need a big fancy wedding or any of
that
i think it'd be nice i'd take a shot at
it but it would be completely different
than anything that i had ever heard in
dating do you think oh my god dating is
brutal
colvin nobody was meeting anybody during
covet okay so and all that crazy exes
came out of the woodwork well you know
they don't look too bad
yeah are you covet free um but yeah
it's hard you know in this business
people understand i was fortunate
and that
i i grew up
my parents had a long
term relationship sure yeah and did you
ever see them fight with each other like
yelling yeah yeah well not really fight
you know they're there because i think
back then there was respect like you
wouldn't do it in front of the game
not in front of like that still was a
big a big thing right
and so they didn't do it in front of
me and my adult sisters they they would
argue in front of my younger sisters oh
why and i don't know but i finally had
to tell i sat him down
and i by this time i was already an
adult i was a cop
and i said okay listen this is the way
it's got to be you know
you're going to be fighting like that
you're stressing out my younger sisters
if you can't get along get a divorce
right oh well good for you work things
out you know because this can't be if
not i'll take the kids if they want to
live with me i'll take them with me
don't you yeah don't do this
and how old were you then i was probably
uh my son that's not [ __ ] richie my
son uh
my son is now
he's gonna be he just turned
i could still date him 44. you're
married he just turned 44.
and and he was
because i was talking to him because he
was just getting ready to be uh born
oh damn so it was that long ago
and so i talked to them and they ended
up staying together they worked things
out and
whatever it was her parents
were
they were long-term relationships are
today's are today's jobs more stressful
than our parents jobs is that a good
question though
like my grandmother went and did the
same thing every day right my dad my
parents were the same way you know was
there everything was more stressful it
was most important work
to my parents and to her parents well
except for her mom her mom would work
what you mean in the home nobody's known
to be outside the home as dysfunctional
as the people are today well honestly i
think
look you only saw one maybe a dude
yelling in the middle of the street like
maybe twice a year right
i blame ronald reagan for that because
he closed all the facilities the mental
health i saw a guy on santa monica and
western who was mentally ill
yelling at people
in their face and chasing people
and it's not that guy's fault but for
safety of all the cities that mental
illness like nobody looks towards the
homeless people who are mental like that
and violence right
and then the other time i told you guys
that that guy was chasing that guy with
that stick
like a pole oh he was so that's too
tight i came here mobile the first one
and i said i grew up here i never saw
that so that guy on the loose like
yelling at
moms with their kids
well i went with luna marie to we went
to the post office the other day and
there was a woman
obviously homeless and mental health
issues
big mental head mental [ __ ] big mental
health issues you know i always ask that
question right she anyway she's
screaming
no she's screaming that she wants her
mail
like
and luna marie is is she in the in the
actual poster in there screaming at the
top of her lungs and she's cussing a
blue streak and lunary was like wow she
had some very creative insults like you
bad ass bacteria [ __ ]
i was like
she she recorded it because she thought
it was the best
insult ever bad ass bacteria
[ __ ]
i think badass bacteria [ __ ]
that's a good one that's a good one that
could be the episode title right but so
she was exposed to that and i was like
darling that woman has mental health
issues she needs help she should not be
homeless she's now as a rapper maybe i
was working
for
uh get started on this department of
children's services walking dead driving
down sixth street through skid row area
they're hall nuts you know out in the
street doing stuff like that i didn't
say there were nuts i said that you know
there's mental illness out there right
well this was
a bunch of it was mostly related to
drugs you know the stuff that they were
doing
okay can you put it out there that we
want people to call from wherever they
are or listening to and whatever city
they're at and let us know what the
homeless situation is wherever they are
oh yeah well kova just exacerbated that
like crazy there there's like villages
set up
everywhere all right
sure we have it at the va at the va but
i'm group which is sad to me because
they're on the outside of the fence
moved him
got got a deal he said and moved him
inside the fence he also cleared venice
beach yeah
and you got the homeless out of there
and not oh not bad not taking everybody
found
and they have those little tiny homes
there they have the tiny homes remember
we said that i went to that dinner over
there at the military and uh they were
all on the street when they showed up
altair did not pay for that endorsement
remember i remember but one of for me
you know because i drive by there all
the time i was thinking and here they
have a proudly displayed american flag
on there and i'm just thinking that is
that is horrible i mean this there's
pride in america but the fact that this
is how we're treating vets and people
that need care
and and they're still have the the flag
and you're like one of the greatest
countries in the world you know what
they are being mistreated a very good
point that you said they're being
distributed every day their illness is
not they're they're sores and they're
the way they feel and their mind and uh
they still fly the flag man yeah
what a good point that is yeah they
still they don't fly upside down like i
did on my wall special anyway we should
be embarrassed though that this is how
we're taking care of them it's not right
and we should be best for the way that
we treat
teachers on those salaries too there's
some like you talk to a teacher and
she'll tell you what she does and then
you're like well how do you like live
so during the la teachers strike
remember they were striking i remember i
was downtown um
uh at the market the grand central
market and someone when you go down
there for it
they have vegan ramen
and the best vegan donuts at donut
friend and this was not a page indoors
i tried to go in the daylight because it
jacked up after the night time and uh as
a single woman it's not good but i
remember being down there and been there
killed the grand central market years
ago i've been there so good i gotta go
man what the [ __ ] they have a place
called egg [ __ ] and they make the
greatest there's an egg [ __ ] down there
i've been to i love it i've never who is
this [ __ ] let's go over there
eggs let's go let's go
so that and grand central market has
ramen hood which is the vegan ramen it's
so amazing but anyway i was only one
ramen note in the in the whole in l.a
and it's down there i've never seen
another one
oh look google that ramen
the la teachers were telling me that
something like 80 percent of the kids in
the l.a county are below poverty level
oh man they're homeless yeah and you're
thinking that is a statistic that nobody
knows and those teachers are trying to
teach these kids it's brutal the minute
the minute that california voted on the
lottery and the lottery passed yeah and
they said that a portion of whatever the
lottery was gonna go to schools it
[ __ ] all the schools up like i don't
think the schools have ever been the
same lausd nobody wants their kids to go
to public school do they give them money
from the lottery to them i don't know
but that doesn't appear like it if you
had to build charter schools you were
building charter schools because you
felt like your kids weren't learning
exactly at charter school but when i was
growing up the us
la la usd was
the the the way you modeled the public
school system for the country right and
then it just went down which is hard to
think like over there at stanford
elementary and i do the toys and all
that stuff a couple times early on i
would say what do you guys need you know
and they're like uh you know what no
what do you need
we need like paper copy paper [ __ ]
pencils yeah [ __ ]
basketballs and soccer balls and you're
just like man this for and if you were
to give if you were to go sub if they
were to submit it and go through the
system it takes forever yeah and
teachers pay for it out of their own
pockets
i mean that's not
right sad it's tragic and not just here
but teachers everywhere which is you
know as rude as kids are normally
talking to somebody in atlanta and then
kids man they're crazy yeah
they had a tick-tock challenge slap a
teacher oh no
i
who was like she was like oh hell no and
her tic-tock she was like taking her
earrings off putting vaseline she's like
little [ __ ] come over here and
slap me and he's gonna see what's gonna
happen
oh my god oh she was like not kidding
around but i mean they they're
responsible for the education of future
generations of american citizens i mean
there could not be a other than doctor
and not the dude from kaiser but the
more responsible job
for the future of america and it's so
underfunded it's awful yeah that's
exactly right yeah
and okay so is it when is it the 17th
with love december 17th put it on your
watch list amazon prime videos
everything all the shows you like on the
watch list yes
done
yeah
and what is is it so you say it's happy
and it says it so what would you what
would you equate it to a show that is
uh 30 something
you know it reminds me of the movie love
actually yeah without the porn storyline
there was a port you never saw a love
action
george it is a christmas you have
holidays
christmas movie you need to watch love
actually it's so it have you seen
actually i haven't seen i wasn't allowed
to watch when i was younger because of
the porn storyline it was a porn
storyline but it's but it's the one was
so lovely there's keira knightley's in
it
um that other english actor who is you
grant no no yes you granted that
but the other one colin
fur no conference the other colin oh
there's two columns
i can't remember what his last name is
but it's such a feel-good
fun movie and all these you know and
it's that that basically is kind of
dealt with love i mean it's a little bit
different but this is kind of one family
dealing with love what traits does
luna marie have that you have
what do you look at her and say
i think body type because she's tall
you're pretty yeah i'm not tall i'm only
five foot five how tall is she
she's already an inch taller than i am
yeah and she's 12.
yeah yeah dancer like she could be yes
but she's more of an athlete i mean i'm
like fascinated that she didn't come out
because you know dancing is my life but
she was more of an athlete i i it's so
funny is i don't think we're very much
what is she saying
um she's acting now she's done two
series and i'm oh yeah you said i i was
reluctant
i was very reluctant because i wanted to
have a degree she wanted to be a
dermatologist i was like go sweetie you
be a dermatologist you keep mama young
forever you invent your own line of
sunblock your own line of makeup you
have your own and she i was like yes
let's do that
and then she discovered in during covid
musical theater and the george lopez
show she had never seen it until then i
showed her one little clip because when
we went to your weed party i was like uh
she needs to know what this guy that you
know who this man is this is where we're
going this is a trip yeah it's a trip
yeah so then during kovitch she was old
enough to deal with you know some of the
topics and she's you know the
dysfunctional parenting in this episode
where we talk about sexually transmitted
diseases i mean it's a lot of stuff for
an eleven-year-old so that one uh the
one we talked about sexual translator
disease was
i think my housekeeper had a kid that
was you know
14 and they showed pictures of disease
to try to scare about where's my vd
where's my syphilis we did that we did
that on the show i remember the lady
went ah oh yeah yeah yeah
you were like wow that color that red
really pops
that was a big episode though because we
did that about sections and then we did
one where bullying
and then the uh steroids we did was a
big one oh right right body play
baseball with steroids was we did some
good things we dealt with uh the
pedophile who moved into the
neighborhood
one of my favorite woman um did the guy
on the mini bike that rope and down the
street was growing up the [ __ ] kids
ride everything back up and down the
street we would chase them yeah so i put
it in the show at the end of the scene
the mini bike and we chase we all chase
them down the street
i know so so we we we did some really
really
really interesting episodes all right so
she didn't discover george lopez until
covid and then she discovered musical
theater in covid and then she decided
she wanted to do musical theater and i
never did musical theater i never sang
um but it's almost a little bit of a
hybrid of dancing and then yeah so so
she just became obsessed and then i did
that show undone and it was so so low
budget we were in a room like this
and it was casting it was makeup it was
hair it was cast holding and she came to
visit me and linda lamonti the casting
director said would she be interested in
reading to play your daughter in
flashbacks and i was like uh i don't
think so
and she said she's like wow no and i
said well you know because i thought
here i am being a hypocrite this is my
kid knows this this is her world from
the time she was two
so okay fine so i did you ever think
about saying no
oh i said no and then
i asked my her dad and he was like well
she's not in competitive sports she
should know what it's like to feel some
rejection you know not to well
i was like fine so let me see i take her
out to lunch and i say i tell her i'm
gonna have to audition with all these
other actresses to play my daughter so
would she run lines with me she had run
lines with me before so she's running
lines with me and we're at cafe
gratitude and over in larchmont and um
in the middle of while we're doing the
scene she puts the paper down and goes
mom can i audition to play your daughter
wow and i was like
let me ask your dad
i thought for sure he was going to say
no yeah
but he had already said yes
so i was like no serious this is really
real and then he said yeah let her try
so i was like fine fine you know what
else is she doing so it was summertime
and i said
make eye contact and enunciate those are
the only notes i gave her and she went
in and they loved her
and then they were like we're going to
show the producers they loved her and
then like ordered some submitted to
amazon i'm like oh god
i gotta bring her dad on board like this
could really be a thing and she ended up
getting which was supposed to be just
one episode and it ended up being five
episodes and she had to do stunts and
learn sign language and do a deaf accent
and she was all over it oh wow wow yeah
so the universe is not working was
conspiring against me no but i applaud
her for being able to do all that oh
yeah yeah she's because i don't want her
to be some little punk who thinks that
she can go on disney and disney i'm like
no no no
i'm like debbie allen and fame this is
where you do it the sweat the blood you
need to know your script you need to
backwards and forwards you better show
up you better be polite tell me from the
bottom of it she is oh no she's got a
little hood there's a little hood in
there
my mom was back i went to fairfax yeah
yeah but my mom garfield high east l.a
bulldogs go back yeah my grandma my dad
as well so my mom brought east la with
her to the west side
all right
thank you for coming by oh my god i can
see you coming by in the future i think
today was awesome this was a real
pleasure
and i'm only ending it because it's
probably two hours already yeah no we're
coming right up on two hours oh my god
so damn where you went how did we start
and then you go when did we start i
didn't even know we started part of the
magic you know this was a great one it
was this one was great it has a lot of
stuff so fun to watch you guys catch up
because it was yeah yeah clearly but i
could see you i could see you being in
here really yeah [ __ ] you don't you come
on down yeah because you brought a whole
nother like me and him that thing but
you also brought things from a feminine
side that we don't yeah you guys don't
have women in here very often
you know they is there like a reason
they don't come here are they scared
and we haven't even haven't lisa eliza
was in here we haven't even manelli no
i'm kidding i'm kidding but i haven't
reached out to anybody like my friends i
ain't come down like we're just like but
we'll start to
do that but you were great yay thank you
thank you
when i was i watch you guys and i'm like
hey
hey porch can i come down here and can
we talk about you know i mean and we
never get to talk because it's always
like an event and it's loud and then
this is the way we talk the way we did
it today is the way that you and i talk
yeah and you saw that the podcast on a
lot of people's
spotifys that it's done well oh yeah i
love it yeah yeah is it real i don't do
spotify i'm old you can let's do it
wherever pandora we're on every podcast
they really like this i think i don't
look at the numbers but
really i think they do yeah
awesome so wait but okay question
is oh my god high
it has its own
site
right it's its own
channel on youtube go on youtube is that
what it is yeah so the episode the video
episodes come out on the atc channel
because this is through all things
comedy the podcast network oh okay so
that's where the videos come out but
then the podcast themselves they all
have their own feed yeah that's what i'm
saying where do i find it wherever so
any podcast app whatever i don't listen
to podcasts
i'm a single mom and i work all the time
they i i look them up on youtube yeah
youtube is great if you if you do omg hi
george or i see it on your instagram
or you can watch them on instagram yeah
we put it's doing good isn't it yeah
especially whenever well he's gonna do
even better because i'm here i think i
think it was i mean this is that was a
real use it was fun
i left a lot of we left a lot of stuff
out i was just awestruck the the stuff
that's coming out about you constance
it's it was beautiful but then your
whole frank and frank and you well that
thing yeah
i didn't know that you shot that on the
show for like [ __ ] how long you did
well because i didn't want to no nobody
and nobody told me yeah yeah because you
would have been mad
yeah you would have been you want
everybody here's the thing everybody
wanted the focus to be on their show and
if there was ever a [ __ ] in my armor or
i was ever not bringing it that would be
the first thing that they would blame so
i was like i don't want anybody to know
anything but greg knew about you because
of that did you think it was hard to do
our show for that long or was the
writing oh my gosh
you know i never
thought between the audience and you and
the family that we built together it was
i remember when it was over
um
i couldn't because remember they told us
that we were gonna you know we had
booked our flights to go to new york for
the upfronts again and like i was
booking out time so i could go to new
york because we were going to get picked
up again and
and then they pulled the rug out from
underneath us and um
i remember because i had to clear out my
room are we still rolling yeah yeah okay
yeah
i did
were you in tears
well i was just in shock you know
because it had gone on so long i didn't
clear my room had somebody do it for me
because i don't think i could well see i
had to because
i needed to i needed to rip the band-aid
off and i remember and i went in the
stage when they were tearing down the
sets and i remember bobby garden that's
going constance don't go in there don't
go in there and i remember i saw them
taking drew carey's stage out to the
trash and i said well that was still on
so i was like i don't want that to
happen to me and i knew it was going to
happen to me so when it was over over we
shot some promos for
the show was already not coming back
yeah and we were like at the last minute
not coming back
but then we had to go in there and shoot
some
promos dressed as the way we used to oh
i remember
and took a picture of me and you holding
hands walking down like the main aisle
by craft service oh will you send that
to me yeah yeah oh wait yeah it was i
needed to i it was almost like i needed
to see the set be ripped down so i could
wrap my brain around the fact that it
was over yeah because otherwise just
[ __ ] throw it in the trash man that's
crazy like it's like that episode of
seinfeld when like this is the merv
griffin stage when they discover it in
the dumpster and like kramer sets it up
in his house because he loved the show i
[ __ ] threw that every everything and
i was taking [ __ ] i was like stealing as
many things as i was like if it's just
gonna go in the trash why can't i have
it as memento and stuff i don't know
what i have what i have our kitchen
table
you do yeah
i've never seen it it's in storage it's
storage and i have
our bedroom our master bedroom bed you
do
that's so crazy the same bed all the
years do you know what i stole
well i had to get rid of it because it
wasn't it wasn't sealed properly and
rain got in and it's sad but you know
the bulletin board that was on the side
where i wrote the positive messages
every single episode i had that for the
longest time and then when i sold my
house
she did wrote she used to write message
on the side of the refrigerator she
would write stuff yeah positive messages
and nobody else
no nobody well just just for you guys
just for us yeah just for us
like you know be the change and yeah the
journey of a thousand miles starts with
the first step
pretty good that was pretty good yeah we
didn't plan that it was just there and
yeah i don't think so it was just no i
was just it was like
there was like random groceries on there
and i was like yeah screw it right now
listening to you two you sound like
a couple that's been divorced that are
just good friends now and reminiscing
like we had a real family we did have a
real exactly right yeah very good times
yeah it was awesome
we did uh
the christmas parade
oh yeah oh but i was mad i never told
you how mad i was no it said george
lopez and cast
not even our names
it's like what the [ __ ] i didn't know
that
people knew you guys george is the one
that ordered the song
[Laughter]
monster frame has no sense
not a paid endorsement
i didn't know that i said that yeah and
then i was like come on okay if we're
going to do this next year
next year okay i'm going to have we
should have our names because it was
bolita i think valentine's day that was
early on because you guys have names
early on second year you didn't have
names yet
oh
see you gotta negotiate with your women
because we don't forget no that's right
though anything we remember second year
cast i remember when we did it
when we went to disneyland at the
beginning that was fun
that episode with the mickey mouse no
when we went there the did the parade
with the they did all the shows that was
the best
that was the best and we had to do what
was it there was a
you know there was like a little mickey
theater or something you know with the
curtain and blah blah blah and people
would do a contest to do an actual scene
from the show with me they would play
you they got to play george
and it was the craziest thing that i'm
doing a scene
from our show with just some rando fan
you know who that fan was frank gonzalez
former party at disneyland
i love disneyland so much we had a good
we had a picture of us on the back of a
car but
she was on my back like over my shoulder
one of my favorite pictures yeah and
you're because you know how he always
does the the things his poses and stuff
and so i'm over like
that's a great person
it looks super cute that was amazing and
my family got to go yeah yeah it was
awesome yeah those were the days that
the people from the shows were
the people that were the most important
and not numbers or money or right they
don't do that anymore no and i remember
they wouldn't let us take a cart around
disneyland because they wanted us to
intermingle with the fans
and that was when that lady
one of the scariest times so i'm walking
around you know and you have a guide
getting you from because we had an
itinerary of all these places we had to
be and of course
so far away in the park but some lady i
walked past her and she screams at the
top of her lungs and i'm terrified i
thought something somebody got shot i
don't know what the hell happened and
it's this older
heavier lady in a wheelchair
stands up
out of the wheelchair
and bear hugs the crap out of me and i'm
like and shit's hot you know how hot it
is at disneyland
she is all sweaty and i am in that and
i'm like and i can't get out i don't
have security just like oh my god i love
you so much and i'm terrified
this lady i i was so scared but but it's
miraculous she could walk she was so i
healed her
she was so
moved by our show that she stood out of
her wheelchair to give me a hug it was
so awesome hey
it's uh there's an article what top 15
shows based in l.a buzzfeed
nice to see that we were included we're
not included in most of the things but
it's nice to see that we were
all right let's go all right time to go
you got your beer buzz on everybody
everybody ready to go uh check out with
love amazon prime december 17th
put it on your my list yes on your watch
list watch list i'm going to do a whole
youtube watch talking people through how
to do it yes